[Music]
hey here we are we might be drunk we're
back we're doing it Nate forgets
everybody what shakes buddy one of our
faves this is exciting for us it's been
a while yeah I know I haven't seen you
in a while I've seen you a couple times
on the road which is fun yeah that's
always fun he just saw Chris Rock down
the road yeah we were in St Louis and he
was in the same hotel and I wasn't going
to say anything but he came over and
hung with us a little bit oh that's
awesome yeah and he was uh and then I
ended up going to his show after my show
and it's like just cool to see jokes in
an arena you know where was it say oh he
was in St Louis Arena what uh is he by
himself he was with Chappelle oh yeah
yeah what do they do does he go
Chappelle goes last and then yeah well
Chappelle uh his private jet there was a
motor problem so rock was like stalling
so he did like 90 minutes and they had
Rick Ingram go up and host in between
like Stalin and Chappelle I was like I
don't there's like a long show yeah I
mean this is it's like probably like a
four hour show did he know you were
there like I mean even they might have
had you go up yeah uh you beat her they
go yeah just stalling for Chappelle yeah
I I don't know if I could be I wonder if
I'll ever be the comic that can be like
I could do an hour all right I'll just
do 90. like I don't I don't know you
don't have it in yet I'm the same way
I'm like I I gotta there's a I can do
what I got yeah whatever whatever yeah
whatever they tell me to do whatever I'm
like I have to do I'm like that I feel
like if I'm doing 60 minutes I'm like I
have 60 minutes yeah I don't feel like I
have an extra minute no no no no because
otherwise it just turns into like is
this anything what's going on with this
guy it just falls off a cliff the
quality goes way down yeah sometimes you
get those crowds where it's like you
need to turn defense into offense a
little bit Yeah and then you that buys
you a few minutes yeah I'm like I have
to fight him a little bit to get him and
now right yeah I don't I don't like uh
you know Jay used to has to do that with
uh good care allowance big J uh
Caroline's for uh Paul Mooney
because I remember because Paul Mooney
would never know he would show up an
hour later always late yeah he would
show up super late thank you very much
man appreciate it don't care for fruit
I'm wondering
but they're uh it was uh yeah he would
show up like an hour he didn't know so
you'd have to go up there it's probably
something good to learn how to do to be
honest and it's it's a it's a weird one
that I don't know where you can really
learn it you have to be in a pretty
unique situation to have to learn how to
do that right you have to have an older
headliner who you have to have an old
book yes who shows up an hour late yeah
yeah you kind of really have to have
that like uh yeah yeah and it's a black
crowd so it's like you're out of your
element a little bit Yeah so it's good
in every level yeah Jay would have to I
mean he had to go up there and just you
know you just didn't know you didn't
know I remember we went up once uh Paul
Mooney didn't show up and then they had
uh he canceled so they knew he was
canceled and then they had us you know
we were doing like the show before that
so they they were like look Paul
Mooney's not coming but we have another
show and then so it was just like in my
like me veter like you know it was like
just not what the people that are there
to see Paul Mooney are there to see Paul
movie and not these two but it was like
it was like a you know one of the like a
showcase show so it's like five white
cops right yeah and five low energy ones
yes yes yeah and meanwhile Paul Mooney's
whole Act is [__] on white people
yes and then here we are the man can't
jump who cares they own the team
material yeah yeah the mindset is just
it's an adjustment yeah he was funny as
hell though Paul Mooney really was a
funny dude I mean it's a legend but he
would he would some he was another dude
that would do like two and a half hours
he felt like it was just sitting there
yeah I I like that's uh maybe you get I
don't know you know I don't try to think
if you ever get to that point where you
just could go up there and you know and
just talk
I don't have that but those guys weren't
putting out specials like you I mean
you're putting out a ton of space that's
true yeah so maybe if like you because
you're not repeating old material
no on the in my hours yeah I mean right
now so right now I have uh because the
special comes out next week third
January 31st Amazon and uh there you go
so for the new hour I did I had a uh I
had like a few I had a few minutes I did
not I cut out of the special so I was
like switch putting that in this new one
but then I I was able to do like an hour
but man this this past weekend I had a
couple I thought like all right I got I
could an hour I can kind of do I don't
really have a closer but I was like I
was able to kind of figure out for this
one way to have a closer and uh I had a
couple good nights where I was like all
right and then I cut then the other
nights I was like making I was like I'm
not gonna hit 30 I mean I could do it I
have like a good 30 minutes that's like
you know what do you do you said the
specials coming up I mean
so I had some people come oh like you
said you're not your closers almost
there not there do you want a new hour
by the time a special comes yeah yeah
yeah that I mean it's very hard it's
very hard it was October and we were
taped and so but I mean I put all new
material you know you put all I put all
this stuff on it uh and uh
uh but I I think I'll have it I think I
had the I had the problem where I had
some people travel like people came
to the show they're like oh we've heard
this material you're like I mean that
kind of took me by surprise yeah which
was very nice but it took me a surprise
to be like well this I mean the
special's not out
and I'm in a new town yeah right so I
didn't think like I didn't think people
were you know I was like well I haven't
been in this town and it's two people
but it still gets in your head yeah you
know if two people have seen your act oh
I had that one I did like I remember I
did like all new stuff in Louisville and
I was like [__] it's like 55 minutes I
don't have anything else so I just did
an old bit and someone screamed at the
punchline and I was like I was like oh I
hate I was so upset with myself it was
weird
[Laughter]
you can sometimes you can make the
announcement I think helps if you go
especially when you're if they're coming
and you go look it's as far as I could
get with new I'm gonna just close with
some but if they're aware it gets it's
exciting and like you know it's like
instead of because I've I learned if you
mix it in and say you do like you did if
you did that if you do 55 minutes and
five minutes old but you mix it in and
don't address it then someone goes he
did a lot of Old Something yes and
you're like no no because they they're
not no one's timing you no one's like
watching you at the time like that so
they just they hear one old thing they
just think oh he's doing I had a mix
recently I got I did three old jokes and
the whole rest of the hour is new and
somebody goes I heard it all heard
everything and I'm like the rest of it's
new I've never done it here and they're
like nah I heard it I was like it was
three news
and but if you say it then there go he
and he was like all new he did an old
joke like and I mean you could you could
probably do 20 minutes of old at the end
but they would would think it's yeah the
other way exactly but I don't know you
know but I got to get new stuff the hard
part to get new stuff now is uh just you
get busy yeah I'm busy and like you're
uh experience yeah doing the Press
you're doing all this press to promote
yeah it's hard to work out and it's hard
to live uh like lit you know go live
normal yeah totally you can't be like I
got this press bit yeah you know that's
not related yeah you gotta do podcast
interviews or do you do yeah
yeah no it's a dream on your diet coke
yeah he goes this guy and I'm just
trying to stretch it out into like a 30
minute oh remember those old days where
you're like I got 20 I could headline I
can just go I just stretch it out I'll
do a little crowd work I'll talk slower
never works that's why I love veterans I
remember when we were all brand new
comics and I'd be like everyone would be
like how much time do you have I won't
be like I got 45 to be open mikers but
they say that should I asked veteran
you'd be like 19.
[Laughter]
you never have as much it's in this this
new hour I thought I because I did an
hour
uh one night and then it was like and
then I mean it was like two nights later
I just cut the grips you have to come
with to go like I mean I'm I'm lucky if
it's a solid 25 minutes like right when
you really if I really look it down like
if the audience is unreal we can do an
hour yeah that's but that's the thing is
you got to play like the worst you're
like what is this for the worst audience
yeah because I was I got I just same
thing over the weekend this is my first
like theater run of shows and I was kind
of like Wow first few nights I'm really
ripping and then I had one the worst
show is at the end and they weren't even
bad but they were the worst of that show
right and you're like this joke's got to
be better yeah it's got to be better you
need those yeah you need them yeah
you're gonna yeah you learn like they're
all great especially like at when
they're coming to see you every show is
going to be great so but you need to
know which ones are bad right because
you can't just go they're all great and
they're not bad bad is not a good you
know if some if audiences listen to this
like you're not saying bad but it's like
comparably like some places are gonna
you know some it's a Thursday night or
it's a Sunday night or it's Saturday or
like and it doesn't matter whichever
ones can be weird or they could laugh
quicker or whatever it is but you gotta
you gotta know because if you're not
aware of that then I think I think if as
the second you kind of become aware of
stuff unaware of stuff is when it all
ends but also too good a crowd can be a
problem like you see that when they're
too good you get confident in bits that
are weak I mean there was that Peak Dane
Cook moment where people were just like
like after his bits I'm like that's not
good for [__] comedy no no no no no
but you gotta if you're you gotta be
aware of it you gotta if you're aware of
it I think you can you know what's
happening maybe you realize all right I
gotta uh I don't know not do a ring you
know like do your Arena thing and then
do it you did it and then back out of it
and then go back to regular I mean there
was like Steve Martin I feel like he
just got too big yeah you can get too
big for the what it is right but if you
set the tone of what you're doing too uh
you know then you can do it forever like
I I sort of like uber like after the
I've talked about today but with Opie
and Anthony when he had the rant the
Philly rant uh I remember going watching
my Caroline's and like people yelling
stuff out and he was like I'm not doing
that like bird was a very good he set
the tone to be like no no I'm I'm gonna
do new stuff and like I'm gonna and now
it's like no one even would ever yell at
the city like it just would be weird if
someone did that so it's he set the tone
for what his show is and being a comic
and you're coming to see this act and
that's what you're coming to see and if
you set the tone for something else you
can get yourself because you know you
start you can set the tone too long
where you just kind of go like well I'll
just do this or I'll all right I'll
roast them for what you know it's like
well quickly that becomes
that's what you're doing yeah yeah and
then okay and then it's like then that's
tough to get to get out to get out of
because then you got to get people back
right when you have to be like I don't
do that I mean how many shows do we do
in New York would be like some high
energy guy then you would go up after
and be like hey everybody and I was like
you made them come to you always that
was something that I remember we all did
a show once and everyone bombed except
you it was it Caroline's because you I
think they were just this awful terribly
behaved crowd and you just got quiet
yeah and they and it was like rough for
the first few minutes but then they by
the end they were like oh she could tell
they respected you yeah and it was like
a cool thing no I mean everyone bombed
but you were the only one who I was like
oh he didn't Pander right yeah you know
and I thought it was cool yeah well I I
I I learned that because I did it I did
Pander on once following like Rory uh
Scoville funny guy I had like uh you
know Festival like Bridge Stone Bridge
Town Bridge town and uh you know he goes
on stage and he does his thing where
he's being Rory and then I kind of try
to go up there with that same energy and
it like went really bad and uh and I
knew not to he did a gay southern accent
well it's like he's you know because
there you're at a you're at a festival
it's like comics and like they love like
you know it's like they love that it's
weird and like all this kind of stuff so
you're like oh I'll try to be weird and
and then I I bombed and I talked to Jay
Larson after he's like yeah because you
try to act like you were a Rory and uh I
was like yeah and I remember and you
know so it's like you learn to like go I
I'll just die with if I'm gonna die I'll
die with what I know what to do
absolutely because it hurts to bomb as
not you oh it's I mean you've you really
really you don't want to handle and eat
[__] that's the worst yeah you really
stick your neck out
I remember I I think of that set a lot
as like okay you can you can there's
ways to change gears and and grab grab
them but there's ways to change gears as
you yeah and you did that that was like
what was a cool moment especially when
we were yeah we learned which material
like you know it's like like I never had
dirty material but it was like all right
but it's like I had marriage stuff so
it's like all right if they were this I
could be like I'll just do marriage you
know right or I'll do if they're young
it's like you just go all right I'll do
I don't know stuff not being married
right like you just end up kind of doing
it's interesting to get to I mean as
you're seeing is a point where y'all
both get you're I mean selling out and
people are there to see you but it's
like stuff has to change because of that
because you know then they know you yeah
and uh and you know and trying to stay
good knowing that they know you because
you know you can get laughs you can see
how Comics could become not good because
they're gonna laugh when you're like all
right if I could just make that they
like me yes so you can get a point to
where you're not being funny but you're
like I'm just I know they like me so
I'll just make sure they keep liking me
for the next hour right but it's like if
you watch it outside of that room or
that whatever it's like yeah but it's
like an a with your crowd and then it
goes to a b you're like oh that joke
sucks this is my crowd and it was still
a b so I gotta work on that one that's
why the seller is great for us when
we're outside because we you know you go
up and you're kind of like that one
didn't do that well yeah and you can't
you can't just blame look yeah it's a
little younger than they were a couple
years ago you can't you gotta you gotta
blame yourself yeah but you're a dude
that's on the road so much I mean like
you I you're a dude I asked for advice a
lot like I see I remember I saw you in
Springfield Missouri and I was in the
club and you were in the theater and I
want to watch your show I'll let you
know
I mean I wouldn't talk to him I'd talk
to him in a separate room yeah
but but I was like oh [__] this and and
I remember you like you were on the tour
bus and you were like this is you gotta
hit every city yeah that's like that's
always been your attitude and it's a lot
of comics don't have the endurance for
that no no they don't and I mean you can
see look you as you know you see the
comics that can uh it looks like they're
touring and selling out a lot and then
it's like we'll go look at where they're
playing and like is it New York Seattle
Chicago you know in L.A you know kind of
the major cities like they're and then
you know and look some Comics don't want
to go play and you know you don't want
to go to Jonesboro Arkansas or you don't
want to go do this stuff but if you look
at like Gaffigan you're like that guy's
built a wealth of fans that you're for
whatever it's worth you can't go that
you're not selling more tickets than
that guy so and as Comics you know where
it's like comic you know sometimes
people can have like the industry love
and all this kind of stuff and there's a
you know and it's like not it doesn't
relate to money but I would imagine it
would be like a billionaire meeting a
guy worth
50 million dollars you know where it's
like he's like no that's great dude I
think that's awesome that you have that
much money you are rich right you're not
him that's a good and there's a
different kind of like you know it's
like that guy's like I'm gonna go to my
plane and fly home he's like no you're
gonna fly in a pride in someone else's
private plane that's great I own this
place like right there's a way that you
can it it it's obviously I'm not I'm not
talking about money in that way but it's
just talking about like getting the fans
like that to be like Gaffigan can go
everywhere like African can take chances
to go he went to Russia I mean he went
to like he can do whatever and go
perform everywhere and see him in Russia
yeah you got to draw the line
I'm not doing that Ukraine you go there
now they got money uh Louis had to show
that Friday that the war started Kiev oh
yeah you know some stubborn comic would
have been like well [__] we're doing the
show dude yeah yeah we're doing it yeah
uh
I mean look at Louie Louie goes around
and can go everywhere and like you're
you're there's a way of that you want to
be able to go to be able to go play
everywhere in the whole country is it's
I mean you see that it's not easy and
it's it's not as easy to to have all of
them be fans sure and that's a that
takes a it takes a lot of work and it's
always worth something going I feel like
there's a way to go you want to go for
it when you know that someone will not
go for it and then they'll tell you why
like well I don't want to be on the road
that much and you're like yeah yeah
because you can't because I don't look
at anything as like you're not making
that choice
you're not making that choice because
you really don't want to be on the road
that much right you're making the choice
because you can't and so you but you say
it and well I don't you know I don't
want to be gone that much anyways no you
would like to be gone that much right
you you went as for this is where you
can stop and you could they could yeah
but that is so much more work to then go
past that and to go everywhere you're
justifying it people I have a sober
friend and I'm always like well I drink
but I can always uh get my [__] done
he's like you're justifying yeah it's
like a sober thing that he always calls
me out on like ah get everything done
and I drink and he's like yeah yeah I'm
like I don't really get that hung over
and if I do I push through and he's like
you see you can't stop uh he's always
giving me [__] same thing with the road
like oh that's you gotta you gotta
connect I don't do those gigs and you're
like you want to do that gig it might be
going up in the city when we're doing
spots it's like you know I don't want to
go to Dangerfield it's like you're like
yeah because you I mean you can't or you
know it's going to be hard and so if
you're not going to something that's
like hard or like put pushing yourself
working out would be you know if you're
not pushing yourself to a limit of
uncomfortableness I'd rather go to
Russian than Dangerfield yeah yeah
that's a pretty rough room it's the same
way it's the same thing that was a uh
that was a tough room that was I
remember the Velvet seats and the uh
bridge and tunnel I remember they would
they would have you do 25 minutes in
there yes and then they the host would
often forget so you're doing like 30 you
end up doing like 32. right there's like
eight people in there I can't wait to
get off you're like where is that guy
dude I was dying because I remember
going at first like 25 minutes do you
know you know how much work I'm gonna
get done in here and then I just be
bombing for 25 minutes yes I remember
one time there was eight people in there
I watched three people they get walked
in to sit down during my set and they
said they give it like one joke and
they're just like and they just walked
out just a humiliating you're doing a
long enough time that they think about
it and leave and it's just one comment
they book a flight to Cleveland that
that club had a grand piano on stage and
by the end of the set like you know you
start by standing next to it then you
put an elbow on it and you're bombing so
much by the end of it you're like
that was uh yeah I mean that was a tough
room because they got it got hard
towards the end I mean no one was going
to it and so you'd go up and it is it's
such a long time to be going up and just
be like what are we you know no those
old sets were epic there there's like
Dangerfield 80s those are like those are
incredible I don't think I you know I've
been here I was here a long time but I
don't know if I was ever here where I
saw that room be it was people started
going to it towards the end before I
right when I was close to moving is when
I felt like people started going back to
that room like they made a you know like
a push yeah but uh I I don't I don't
ever remember Dangerfield's being uh
I remember I mean the comic strip was oh
yeah pounding when I was here that's
what I started yeah that was the club
that still can be great I've done some
private shows and it's so electric and
you're like I get it this room's amazing
the room is electric the Acoustics it's
like a perfect I mean Seinfeld did the
special there right Sandler did parts of
the special there and I I think that
gave it like a boost and then I think
they just threw it away again but yeah
the head shot is it still going or yeah
that's still going yeah yeah
yeah yeah
got a show there on Wednesday if you
want to pop in yeah no pressure all
right well I guess that's I'll still go
come by but yeah I was just at zany's in
Nashville which is weird to be in
Nashville and you were on the road I
know but
Lucy who runs Zanies was like I saw the
Nate hour it's his best one yet
so I'm excited for this one yeah I was
this uh
I I mean I like and I really enjoyed
this this was a
material like I felt like it was like I
was excited to sh like to do it like you
know like where you're you feel like you
have an actor you're like oh man I'm
like every city I went to I was like
excited to wow I enjoyed it and I was
almost like when I take the special it
wasn't like I was so over it you know
there's be Parts I was kind of over
telling but uh there was a lot of it I
still really liked you didn't get bored
with the hour at all I did not get yeah
and I did a lot of shows but I really
and it was fun it's like I'm trying to
find that you know because you always
live in your act you have jokes that are
you know you have some parts that you're
like uh yeah you know it's like it's
there but you're like I'm just saying it
like I don't really enjoy it and people
can enjoy as under the audience doesn't
but you just you're like it's not as fun
as this part and so like I tried to like
that was the closest one where I feel
like I had the the most fun uh and like
that's what I'm trying to do this new
era because you're like how can I have
like I should want to be like I can't
wait to get in every part of my ACT yeah
and I you know it's like uh
it's hard to do though how do you do it
man how do you come up with so much
material yeah I don't know you push it
out it's incredible yeah you're a tank I
mean and uh I don't know how how do you
make the decision to go from Netflix to
Amazon for this one uh it was Amazon
Amazon's making a big push like a comedy
uh push into comedy and the and they
were very excited and they uh wanted me
to come up there and kind of be the uh I
guess start of that and so they're
they're really kind of doing a thing
where they want to do stand-up comedy
and uh I think stand-up comedies they're
showing it's doing really good there now
all right uh so they want to be a I
guess you know a player in that game and
uh so they were very excited for that uh
pretty good pay that was good
[Music]
it would to be honest it would uh yeah
well I don't know it's I I did not I was
it was it it is okay it but it's I I
took uh but I took less oh it was uh for
in exchange for more ownership I own it
wow that's worth it yeah it was uh yeah
so it's you know I license it with them
and then uh I own it and then I could do
it so yeah owning it was a very big huge
and it was uh and I do think Amazon is
uh they're gonna make a big push and
they're gonna and to be a part of and do
some nudes yeah yeah it's nervous like
going over because it's like Netflix has
the audience and right Netflix changed
my life and I have nothing and I love
Netflix and it's uh
so it's yeah Netflix is awesome uh but
going to Amazon was it was just like
where I was at
that uh you know it's like all right let
me just see if you know if I I think
this will hopefully be the right way and
owning it was big yeah I did want to own
it hell yeah I wanted to you know
like having it it's weird because owning
it like you know how you don't ever you
don't ever get like it's always hard to
get your own special when you're like
yeah when you tape a special then you
want to be you think they're going to be
like here it is you can have it and then
you can post it like you know you know
you don't own it but you just and
they're always yeah I don't think you
ever really get it you always like
there's like a way that you know they
give it to someone for streaming it or
like so people can look at it before you
they watch it oh when they say it's on
Paramount plus a special I'm like just
dump it in the toilet yeah just put it
in there they don't even have [__]
Yellowstone on Paramount plus they have
the other Taylor Sheridan shows oh
really yeah if you want to watch one of
his other shows and 900 comedy specials
that come to Central flush yeah yeah
give it a go isn't that your last draw
with Comedy Central when they said you
couldn't clip your own show yeah like
I'm doing that YouTube from now on yeah
on comedy Central's YouTube channel but
they let me clip it yeah there you go
but that was you know that was a fight
even you know what they're always I
think Comics are always a step ahead
with everything because we're in you
know the clubs every night so we know
who's funny before they do yeah and we
know kind of what's working before they
do and I saw the clips were working on
this week at the Comedy Cellar and we
were just burning topical jokes because
I'm not going to hold on to a headline
joke yeah and they wouldn't let us post
it and I was kind of like what are you
doing and it'll help you you think you
think I want to write a joke I want to
write like five topical jokes that are
funny jokes that are only gonna air on
TV where like three people are gonna
watch it yeah well you know folding
laundry or beating off in the back no
one's paying attention this year no yeah
beat off to my YouTube channel exactly
yeah that's what I say
yeah
yeah they've made some mistakes but
where are they now
yeah they laid off a lot of good people
it's not a good thing it's not a good
story it's not like a happy story
you showed them though
well it's scary because you never know
what the new thing is like when we
started Comedy Central was the end-all
be-all or maybe HBO and now you're like
[__] that then you're like HBO I don't
even know if I would whatever and then
who knows if Netflix will go away
and you set up a good tour like I I
asked Gary a lot I'm like would Nate do
this I'll do that sometimes like what
does Nate do can I just trust what you
would do because you've been mean
but uh yeah but you know you bring a
good crew with you on the road your toy
manager is like a childhood friend yeah
you both surround yourself with good
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's uh uh you
want to create the hang and the like
it's being you you want to be funny like
you're you know going up and doing Club
spots and hanging out in New York City
like that was like that's where we were
all being funny all the time and making
a lot of jokes and uh and you it's hard
to do that when you start touring
because you're gone really and so you
bring all comics and I bring two Comics
to open and it's uh just to you know so
it's we have a fun like after every show
like we where it's a lot of jokes it's a
lot of like you know being funny and
it's just trying to almost that you know
that seller table Vibe it's like you
gotta check out a take it with you
because otherwise you're going to be out
there alone and then you're and that's
going to be easy to kind of just get
lost in your own self totally because
you're getting told you're great all the
time or all this stuff and uh uh you
need to you need to be with Comics that
are you know I don't know it's like that
we've all known each other forever right
and so you get to hang out with them and
then and then you're fine and then I
always think about the show I'm bringing
where it's
I'm bringing Comics that are like
everybody's on TV and everybody's done
stuff and so the show that these people
get to go watch is uh pretty great and
they're like you want to it's like yeah
and then everybody's gotta be clean on
my show obviously but it's like so like
with clean comedy is like you know we
just did Mike vecchione's special and uh
one of my favorites yeah so it was like
making his special and like the crowd
getting to see him and stuff it's like I
have an audience that a lot of times or
so some a lot of people don't care about
being clean or not clean or whatever a
lot of fans that are fans of you guys
you know that come up and say stuff and
tell me that and but then there's fans
that are there because I am cleaning so
like you're trying to it's like to give
the someone like Mike vecchione to like
a clean comic or like you know he was
always kind of basically clean like so
it's like to give that audience to see
him it's like they just don't always
gonna see that level of comic yes that
they would get to see and there's so
many guys Becky Owen is hilarious 20
years follow Mike Vecchio on social
media private special come out Brian uh
March that's phenomenal he's also his
album uh what's the worst kind of
thoughtful is that the name of his album
as well which is also yeah muscle
confusions he's a 10 minute joke on the
bus that's one of my favorite jokes oh
really he's so funny and such a great
guy but there's so many guys like this
who are so funny and underrated and just
silently killing all over the country
but the industry kind of won't throw him
a bone that's why it's great when guys
like you or other headliner Comics can
well he's a hello Mike 61
000 followers on Instagram his joke uh I
love his joke about how he signed us to
be a private detective online yeah and
they uh and they just took his money and
he thought either I just got ripped off
or this is my first case it's amazing
yeah great great he has so many jokes
like that he's got stuff I mean he Mur
murders when he goes out and that's
what's great is because I have to follow
that too so it helps me
uh it makes you like stay yeah you have
to be good like I mean because they're
it's like I mean they're watching uh
a great show before I get out there and
so you got to live up to the hype and be
better and like not be better but like
be as good as these guys yes
that guy's funnier played hockey he's a
pro hockey player but Mike vecchione our
micro vecchion has a thicker neck
somehow this is that's crazy that he he
plays for the Philadelphia Oh weird
that's true holy [__]
uh Philadelphia comic yeah he has so
many good jokes and he's also just a
great dude I mean he's one of my
favorites oh yeah he's the best but yeah
I mean that's the thing with like I I
want it to be a good show too veterans
with me all the time I love videos
unbelievable and I mean the first night
of the tour we were in New Orleans and
Amy Schumer and her husband Chris come
out and they're just watching Gary and
they're both like bent over dying
laughing I mean that's such a great
feeling that you're like this is the
dude I bring he's just murdering
all of them think they're doing pretty
good and you keep going I mean another
guy nowhere
nowhere in this business lucky to give
me goodbye lives at the YMCA probably
yeah I don't know [__] I don't know
what he's gonna do yeah I don't know I
just don't see how he he'd be he makes
it through hopeless oh yeah yeah I'm
gonna be on the street
is that a set list or a suicide note I
don't know yeah sorry Gary we're pushing
for you go book Gary
he's got like a great career but just
what they feel to be more well known no
I know what you mean they in in we know
how funny it is
it's a lot of comics I mean now and it
skipped over a lot of comics said but
that's the thing dude if young Comics
like if you just go on the road I mean
knock on the road even if you're in the
city wherever you're at just go and ride
jokes and be funny and like that stuff
if you stay that way you build your you
know what is it saying like a house on
stilts or like what like uh what is the
house on
uh I don't know Katrina I don't know you
got to build high up
it's it's I don't know
no what's the saying that your house now
we're really getting away from what he
said yeah but it's a if you're building
it's you should build your house on
concrete or something not on stilts
maybe that's it but I don't know if
that's the saying I don't know Gary
being sure take this as far as yeah it's
weird that but people Katrina I blame
back I blame Bad Comics for Katrina and
uh but like if you you built something
all you know like concrete that can't be
taken away from you your material yes is
all that you that cannot be it's your
worth it's your it's uh back what makes
you it's like it's the thing that people
don't have like your material cannot be
taken away from you see our first two
specials on Paramount plus yeah it got
taken away from us and then you build
more material yeah so it's like that's
the more you get the more you can't once
you learn how to build it even though it
feels like you're never gonna you know
it's it's impossible to build there's
never you think there's a solution
there's not a solution because they said
here in Matthew 7 Jesus said everyone
who hears his words and puts him into
practice is like a wise man who built
his house on a rock
yeah there's no stilts in there but I
got you all right there you go that
counts okay in the Bible too so there
you go
um
we everybody I'll read some of that
sometimes
take a gander at it uh I have a joke
Bible on my toilet yeah there you go uh
it's not the same I like the Koran yeah
yeah but they're yeah there you go when
you want to look your best the only
place to go is the black tux the black
tux makes it super easy to get top
quality guaranteed to fit tux without
leaving your house
just take the black tux fit quiz pick
the style you want to rock and boom your
tux is delivered 10 days before the day
you need it that's plenty of time to try
it on and make sure it wears you well
and hey if it's not quite right say
hello to the black tux fit guarantee oh
yeah I do declare order a better size
within a day of receiving the less than
great fitting one and they'll send
another right away at no extra cost I
I've heard this stuff's great I gotta
try it I think they're gonna send us one
Mark I can't I wore it at my wedding I
mean that's the biggest uh yeah what's
that the biggest endorsement you can say
wore it at the wedding I bought two I
bought a blue one and a red one and I
put the red one on for the afternoon
when are they gonna send these to us I
don't know I gotta send my size I don't
know how to measure myself I'm not good
at this stuff yeah yeah
thingy winkies bro oh yeah and if and if
you prefer an in-store experience the
black tux has showrooms across the
country they're expert fit Specialists
will help you find the perfect style tux
or suit and make sure it fits just right
rent or buy the black tux is the best
place to go and you need a tuxedo for a
wedding or special night and right now
when you go to theblacktucks.com drunk
and use code drunk you'll save 10 that's
blacktux.com drunk that's B the
so it's theblacktucks.com shrunk
t-h-e-b-l-a-c-k-t-u-x.com slash drunk
save ten percent the blacktux.com drunk
yeah yeah hey folks it's hard to keep up
with a supplement routine that comes
with a bunch of different products I
hate it just start with one ag1 by
athletic greens it's the morning jump
start you need just scoop shake and have
a long side your morning coffee I'm
hooked I drink it every day I know
you're hooked dude you we I got extra
and I take it on the road this stuff's
keeping me from getting sick on the road
same it's tons of vitamins as I throw a
bunch of packets in my suitcase 75
vitamins and minerals and a major boost
to your gut mood energy skin hair and
nails ag-1 gives you increased energy
and mood support making it easy to live
your best life if you're looking for an
easier way to take supplements athletic
greens has given you a free one-year
supply of vitamin D and five travel
packs with your first purchase go to
athletic greens one word.com slash drunk
that's athleticgreens.com drunk check it
out
why are you still paying insane amounts
of money every month for your phone bill
mint mobile lets you order from home and
save with phone plans starting at just
15 a month making saving money by
switching them in the easiest New Year's
resolution to complete you've given up
on all the other ones let's face it
loser all plans come with an unlimited
talk and text plus high-speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5G
Network love your current phone no
problem use your own phone with any mint
Mobile plan and switch easily in minutes
with esim to get your new Wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month and get the
plan shipped to your door for free go to
the mintmobile.com
drunk that's mintmobile.com drunk cut
your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
at mintmobile.com
drunk I just realized can we get Steph a
stool oh okay all right I was just
wondering if you're on your feet those
whole hours all right
yes that's literally what popped into my
head too
today's episode is sponsored by PayPal
honey the easy way to save when shopping
on your iPhone or computer learning
about a deal makes you feel like an
Insider someone in the know honey is the
free shopping tool that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best one and fits finds it to your cart
it supports over 30 000 stores online
ranging from Tech and gaming products to
Fashion to popular brands and even
delivery you gotta love it I bought some
new Nikes typed in the old honey
Big Discount get on it save some money
why not you shop online all the time
anyway imagine going to your favorite
site when you check out the honey button
appears and all you have to do is Click
apply coupons wait for a few seconds as
honey searches for the coupons it can
find if honey finds a working coupon
they'll match it to you and watch those
prices drop I love honey and you will
too I never go shopping without it honey
doesn't just work on desktops it's on
the iPhone 2 just activated on Safari on
your phone and save on the go if you
don't really have honey you can be
straight up missing out on these deals
I'll tell you that by getting it you're
doing us yourself a solid and supporting
the podcast get PayPal honey for free at
joinhoney.com
wmb that's joinhoney.com
wmb wmbd
oh God
wmbd we might be drunk join honey.com
wmbd
get honey pal oh [__] get PayPal honey
for free at joinhoney.com
wmbd that's joinhoney.com wmbd
of that photo good pick this show is
sponsored by betterhelp when you feel
empowered you're more prepared to take
on everything life throws at you therapy
can get you to that place I'm in therapy
marks in therapy oh yeah we we do
therapy I think it's I think it's hey I
don't think everyone needs it but if
you're one of those people who thinks I
don't need it you might need it yeah
it's like when a girl says don't wear a
condom yeah wear that condom yeah better
help is the therapy option that is
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online fill out a brief
questionnaire get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
at any time no additional charge easy if
you want to live a more empowered life
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com drunk today to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
help.com drunk if you you know like yeah
I always remember like actors like you
see that you're like God you're just so
reliant on yes so many other like you
put your whole career is and and they
can be great actors and get past that
and people want that and they like that
thing but it's like like writing a show
like you know you go audition for stuff
and you're like dude I don't I'm just
it's up to these people if they like me
or not yeah and versus if I just do my
act or if I write my own TV shows it's
like you know you're in you're just a
little more in control hell yeah and
then they need to go to you because
it's hard to create stuff there's not
that many people that can create stuff
not just that but Comics really help
each other and I was talking to a
musician friend of mine the other night
and he was telling me like yeah we don't
really do that in our world really well
like yeah they're not really pushing
each other Comics push each other like
we all like Nate's producing a friend of
his special you know we're posting clips
of comics we like we're promoting Comics
we're doing each other's podcasts I
don't think every world is like that and
and we're creating [__] and not Reliant
waiting on industry to tap us
auditioning I get auditions now and I'm
like why I hate it I turn them all down
yeah yeah I never got one I never got
one either hey but I did for your show
didn't get that either but never I
remember that I was hungover yeah I
still when I'm hungover I can still do
[__]
yeah y'all didn't play me
that's what they brought you in just to
get like if I didn't work out they were
like don't worry
Lewis Black audition to play himself on
a pilot yeah your audition was tough I
had this whole thing about stilts it
didn't work yeah but he goes built on
still it's like it doesn't make sense I
go but it's definitely not the writing
yeah
it was doing doing that when we when I
did shoot that pilot and everybody
auditioned for that it is in like that's
almost it's eye-opening to see who comes
in for it it's pretty crazy it's famous
people that's why you're like any names
you can mention uh I try to think I mean
uh Kristen alley I met Christina Kirsten
rip yeah yeah uh but like uh she was
like playing my mom and uh I mean my
parents said we ended up casting where
uh Joe were up and Kirkwood Smith oh wow
that was my parents wow is that weird to
just put them back together
they're back yeah well we were we were
trying to do it and uh they were on I
mean they're just professionals it's
pretty fun to see the like that world be
professionals we shot that pilot so we
did in front of live audience uh and uh
Kurt wood like what you know because
they're coming and throwing you jokes
like it's fun multicam is very fun and
uh for a comedian because it's a lot of
like on the thing we're like Hey we're
gonna change this joke you're gonna do
this blah blah whatever right and then
uh
but kurtwood would I mean he would lay
down on the couch in the living room
couch the whole live audience is
watching and he just closed his eyes and
just lay there and you're like the
comfortableness
that this guy could have
and just like there's people there it'd
be like if you went on if you just laid
on the couch on the stage that's crazy
and you and just and then they're like
all right ready to go and he's like all
right and he gets up and just goes and
does it I mean he's been around he's a
great actor RoboCop that's right [__]
killer in that movie terrifying but yeah
but these are they were talking about
Mike vecchione as like a murderer these
are amazing actors that may not be like
household names for everybody but think
about how many actors there are too that
could just like knock your socks off
they yeah maybe the average person
doesn't know oh totally like they would
do it you would see it we had one uh
girl I don't remember her name she was
she did uh uh she was British she did
British and an English accent in this I
mean same audition just switched it up
in English
British American and uh so she did a
British accent first and then she did uh
who do the like a southern American
accent that's incredible and then you're
like just doing it in front of your face
and you're like you're like oh my gosh
we uh what's his face from uh uh home
alone uh the tall uh General Stadium he
came in how's he doing uh hilarious he
came in he was yeah he is hilarious by
the way oh really yeah fun fact uh wow
he came in and uh he was great he was
great he was it was
uh yeah it was like he's just it's him
you're right like it's like I think he's
a little crazier now as he's gotten
older you know like chewing on guy yeah
I don't know if he's that well that
Randy Quaid is one that I did think of
and uh great actor yeah but he was like
but it was I think it was right when he
was where he was like oh he's like gone
yeah it's it's it's even not even like
his beliefs you're like no no I think
it's like he's you know something behind
the eyes you're the guy he plays in
Another Teen Movie like I think he's
become that dude
oh oh exactly the dad on that yeah yeah
that's true I can see that he's got the
weird pilot yeah from the 40s yeah no
he's a great actor though man I mean he
and he's around for [__] ever you
look back you're like the students in
movies in like the early 70s I know I
know you know yeah it's so crazy but
just the fact he had a TV show pilot
thing is insane that that was happening
yeah I mean I've written a bunch of TV
shows none of them go they are that was
the only one we shot a pilot are you in
a place where you don't need it yeah I
mean I I still I I want to do one just
but it's like now let me tell you it
gets it's nice when you it's a lot of
work uh
uh but it's something but it's it's it's
uh you know I mean we're all Seinfeld
guys so we're all like that like we want
what he did and uh all right I mean I
you know I do it's like seeing Ray
Romano like seeing all those guys do
these shows and uh so I want to do that
uh whether it happens I don't know but
it's you try shooting the pilot was I
mean it was fun it was like you're it's
just so different yeah and uh but it was
very fun it was it was did you think it
while you're doing it did you think it
was gonna go
yeah I mean you you know when you walk
out dude it's like you know it was just
called the neburg Etsy show and you're
seeing I mean hey seeing the people
audition for it is insane it's it's
because it's it's people that you know
and it's people that you are like oh my
gosh like I can't believe like this
guy's famous yeah and then they're there
and then uh uh uh Shooter McGavin came
in wow he did like and then they're like
oh but everybody's just like it says
they're a big fan yeah wow and like
they're so all these people come in and
he came in from shooting uh
the he was in the Dwayne Johnson TV show
like whatever the rock showers or
whatever yeah Ballers yeah and so it's
it's all these dudes and you're like you
can't believe because you just you know
it's a comic we always feel like we're
just like yeah like we're I don't know
we're going to ask to leave every room
and so and it would be nice to you
you're the guy
and you're sitting there and they're
saying stuff and then uh I remember uh
Katie Hazleton who we did she played she
played my wife in it but I did not read
with her at first because I was like
nervous I didn't want to read because a
I was like I don't want them not like
I'm who knows if I'm awful at this right
so I don't want to be bad and then they
don't get to park because they're like
ah like she didn't look like she wasn't
that good and you're like no she was
awesome like I'm a train wreck you're so
much more considerate than the average
most times yeah she sucks who gives a
[__] oh I felt and so I didn't read with
her but I didn't know that whole world
was like she was coming in to read with
me like that you know you know your
level of audition where sometimes you go
and you're like all right no one from
the show is going to be in there yeah
and that's one audition and then
auditions like the producers are in the
room then the audition's like well
you're reading with the person in the
thing yeah so you know like all right
you're in a small group that's only
going to be reading with those people
right and so then I was like I didn't
want to read with her and then uh like I
talked to her afterwards and she was
like oh I mean really like kind of taken
back by it because it was It was
supposed to be she's reading with me
because she's a big time actress and
like so it wasn't like you know she was
supposed to come in and just reload and
I was like I don't I don't want to do it
I I didn't do it on purpose I didn't
know that yeah and so she thought it was
like a bad thing and I was like oh no I
didn't I didn't know I was supposed to
be doing it what network was nice uh ABC
we were at Fox then ABC it would have
been on ABC uh it would have came out
right before covet and uh
uh yeah we we did an episode on spanking
and uh I kind of I regret that a little
bit uh just because it was just because
it was like you gotta when you make a
show you're making it like you know they
show it to people and you know in your
head you're thinking like all right
we'll do a show where the daughter does
get spanked and you know trying to do
something where it's like instead of
like
trashing spanking like talk about you
know whatever and it's just like too
it's not fun it's uh
and for that to be the first thing they
see that was a pilot that was the pilot
it was racy for you uh yeah yeah it was
a it was uh I I just wish I would have
done that I wish I'd done like I don't
know I've done something more just fun
did you get notes while you were doing
it uh yeah you get notes I mean they you
do when you do a run through I mean it's
the ABC the president of ABC and all of
them they just come sit in chairs and
you do the whole thing in front of them
was that stressful uh yeah yeah I mean
you go I mean they then they go give you
notes after that and I told them I was
like because I was a you know a Creator
executive producer on it and everything
so I'm supposed to be in every kind of
notes but I was like I don't want to go
up because I was like I wanted to give
them the freedom to be like I stink like
if they want to say I'm terrible I want
them to be like okay that's okay they
can say I'm terrible yeah but what do
you do with that if they wouldn't I mean
they can you have a thing where they can
uh cast you out of it where like you end
up yeah well then you're like so
Whitney's uh when you come and show uh
no she didn't get cast out of it but
like she had those two shows yeah
Whitney and then Two Broke Girls so you
just become that where you're the
Creator and like she was on Two Broke
Girls was she cast out of that no no but
she created that show I think and so
like I mean
right uh but like you would just be like
that kind of situation where you're just
not in it but yeah you can get cast out
like you can't I want that wouldn't that
shatter you uh I mean it would it
wouldn't it wouldn't like because as a
comic it would be hilarious to go tell
everybody that I was terrible like I
would look at it like that where I would
be like man how funny would that be to
go you wait your whole life just to be
cast out of this but I think it would
still hurt it would crush it would crush
me and hurt but it's like I it wouldn't
I I wouldn't spiral like I think with
comedy you just have I can still go on
stage I'm not gonna spiral out of it
like I mean this was written where where
you're like it's going to be tough to
cast me out of it and I did it and you
write it to your strength yeah if you're
writing it yes I'm being very protected
I'm making sure like yeah there was no
like I was like I'm not like there's no
crying I'm not gonna do like there's you
know there's no anything that involves
like crazy acting like I don't want a
bunch of big laugh like I don't have to
laugh right like I'm not I'm writing it
very protective of myself the way you
deliver it yes I also I'm a believer
that if like you're writing your own
show like any comic can do that it's
what you look like on stage like you
could do it are you uncomfortable are
you gonna be awkward are you going to be
you know what what does it feel like and
and I did find out when ABC when I
didn't go do that notes they were like
oh they wanted me up there because they
were like no no we he was all like they
would they I did it I was I was doing
great and I would ask a lot like I would
you know you got a lot of people around
you Greg Garcia who created uh My Name
is Earl and a bunch of others so me and
him come very close and he uh Danielle
Sanchez was the showrunner and she
brought in Greg which is funny because
Greg was helping us and she brought in
Greg and I didn't know Greg at that time
so it's like a dude that like comes in
and like writes like you know punches up
he's but he's doing a lot more than that
he's like held us with the structure of
the joke but I don't know who he is at
first and I'm like who's this guy think
he is and then you're like oh this guy's
created Five sure my Name is Earl Yes
dear oh wow I mean he's created Five and
what and what was he like what kind of
note he's the hey if you ever y'all
should meet him he's the best one of the
best writers I've ever been around I
mean it's uh he's a kind of a Phenom
kind of person uh very down to earth
very normal and like he's just great at
like making a show so I would ask him
and because he would tell me Danielle
would tell me like just be like yo am I
terrible like am I doing and they would
like they're just they're like no no
it's like you you know that you're all
right the problem's not gonna be because
I'm awful at acting like if you don't
get picked up it could be for whatever
reason but it's not because I'm awful
right but in a show too but if someone
is bad they cat you have to cast them
out so like we had a girl play our
daughter and like there's a moment of
where you're thinking like if they go
and like have any conversation about her
which there was a little where you're
like so you have to fire this girl oh
you're I mean there's a point there
where you're like I'd quit I'd just quit
the show like like I'm not gonna do that
it was worse than spanking a little girl
yeah yeah well we hit her on the show
but yeah it's you're but I mean having
to like you know you meet that girl's
family and like the girl's funny and
she's sweet and were you at the fire no
no no no no no no no no we argued
because we were like we're not wow like
because you're just going like there's
no way that's that would be a problem
whatever it's like they're giving you
notes and stuff like that but you're
like it can't be getting rid of like
that's insane yeah Jordan Rock was in it
who did he play in it
[Laughter]
he was uh
uh he he played in there's a golf uh
shop that we go in and he played in that
and so he would have he was uh like he
was like a guy that grew up in the he
would have been a guy that grew up in
the town you're a golfer too which is so
so you're like one of the younger golfer
comedians it's Santino plays golf you
play golf I remember when we were in
Ireland together all of us were just so
freaking fun that was such a difference
but you were the one guy that we're like
where's Nate he's golfing 30 miles away
like 11 A.M yeah we I had to go golf the
Rory's scoville's buddy because Rory was
supposed to come and got Amy's movie and
couldn't go all right and so his buddy
was coming to play with us so then Rory
just left and was like and so I just
played with his buddy from high school
all weekend but his buddy was awesome so
it was hilarious but he was like yeah it
was funny to be like I gotta go you know
what's crazy a guy we go uh one day we
go play at one of the courses so in a
lot of courses of their uh they don't
have driving ranges like we do here it's
like you just go play and uh so I'm
playing and I start talking to this one
kid and he went to my high school whoa
over there I mean he was much younger
but yeah what are the odds over there to
be randomly golfing at some course and
this kid uh went to my high school
that's wacky yeah let me listen about
the TV show and then I'll leave it alone
what would you rather though would you
rather have the show not go or the show
go and fail
I mean if you have a choice if you have
a choice like look at how many yeah if
you have a choice I'd rather shoot the
pilot in the show not going and fail but
right it's uh just because it it just
doesn't matter I mean obviously it did
not hurt Mulaney no he's great but
I you know it's like
I don't know it's like I mean the part
of it is you want to see if you can win
them over I mean that's the right that's
the idea of maybe you get a cult
following there and that helps set up
another show right yeah it could I mean
it shows that that made it that lasted
one yeah yeah yeah true yeah I mean
yeah I I don't know that's a tough
question because it's like you would I
mean if you knew for sure it wasn't
going to fail I mean I don't know why
we'd even do it I mean I'm glad I shot
the pilot because it's like I did get to
learn that that was a lot when you see
your name on everything and you realize
how many people are working and that
audience is there and then it's like
when I walk they introduce you like they
introduce like you know in Seinfeld and
they walk out and then I went out and
talked on the microphone almost started
crying uh at the microphone like yeah
and I never had that really in my career
wow but it was such a like I can't
believe like it's you're like I can't
believe I'm here I can't believe I'm
gonna walk through a door that's fake
and go to a kitchen and and they and
when they make the house and you're you
tell them how you want the house and
they have a newspaper That's The
Tennessean which is our local newspaper
I mean they have like the Titans
calendar as a magnet on the football I
mean every detail looks like you're at a
home in Nashville and so you're
Tennessee Royal Theater yeah yeah that's
why I try to tell them you know and
but it's like everything there's a show
that goes with it but it's it's all that
stuff is you know I mean yeah like we we
obviously love Seinfeld yeah we talked
about Seinfeld all the time and like
being able to create something that
you're like you can walk me in I
remember in uh clusterfest yes they had
that it's always sunny too they did pass
yeah yeah so yeah I I never watched
Always Sunny my sister's a giant fan of
that maybe the best sitcom in the last
20 years yeah yeah and it's like it was
uh but like with Seinfeld is that when
you walk in there and you see that couch
and you see you know the thing it's like
I want that like you want to create that
and like if you saw everybody love
Raymond's set like you like I I I want
to do that like I want to go bit I want
to go after something big like that
otherwise it's like I don't know it's
like making a whatever you do with your
stand-up so why yeah why take your foot
off the gas with this [__] well I mean
it's different it's it's it's different
but I'm saying like why not take a home
run swing like why make a show if you're
not trying to make a great show it's I'm
in in my where I'm at my career now it's
like I kind of look at it as like all
right if I want to do a show it's like I
want to do it I want to try to swing for
the fences or I'd rather not do it like
do you know romano and any of those guys
were you would say hey I'm making a
sitcom I need advice yeah yeah uh I mean
the last one I made one that didn't go
was with Phil Rosenthal wow and so he
created her brother's room but uh I know
Ray pretty well and so I when I first
did it when I first was doing one I
talked to him about it and uh there's a
party said to me where it was I thought
I was gonna like I really because we we
had a pilot like Fallon this is one that
Fallon was doing so it was a while ago
and uh so Fallon produced it yeah yeah
foul produced it and it didn't Letterman
produced Romana yeah so that's like an
old school kind of stuff so there's no
school setup so I mean it was like this
is where you think stuff is like you're
like wow this is lining up to be like
exactly like everybody was trying to do
like and then so by the time mine
raised show came on he was 37 years old
by the time I went on I would have been
probably 37 years old and then found's
doing it and Letterman did his so I had
all these things and I'm like man it's
happening and then it just doesn't
happen and so but you learn stuff in
that moment sure you will have these
giant things that you think if this
fails like it's over I'm done and then
you just you just keep you go back to
stand up
it took off around that time yeah well I
mean everything else go but I'm saying
you you have these moments where you
there's there's the longer you do it the
more you realize you there's the you
can't put much pressure on everyone yeah
there's just not any pressure on it
because you don't know what the thing's
gonna be you don't know what is the
thing that's going to be the thing that
makes it like go but if you're around
and you keep putting stuff out
eventually you know you're yarding your
audiences by Word of Mouth essentially
you're getting this someone's going
watch this guy whether it's Clips or
they're coming to see live and then they
come back and see live and you put on a
great show then then you got to look at
your shows are gonna double you know you
just did eight shows at Zanies or
something which isn't ten so that's
that's I mean you're doing a giant you
know I mean that's that's three thousand
tickets like it's I mean that's you do
you would do a big theater there next
time you go you can almost be like 5 000
is what it's going to be and like or you
know so it's like you just look at like
that kind of thing two rhymings next
time you go you might do two rymans or
whatever you want to go do but it's
gonna double as long as the show people
are leaving and they're happy it should
it will double like it just keeps
doubling I always worry about it going
away like you're doing so well now huge
rooms big tickets
what do you you know 10 years is a long
time like a lot can happen in 10 years I
mean looking like a guy like Dane Cook
he was on top of the world and now he's
you know he's still doing it but it's
not what it used to be and I always have
that fear I I I I have the I have the
same fear it's we're I it's I think like
being a comic here dude I think we're we
talked uh like they were it's as long as
you're aware of it and as long as you're
you have that fear when the fear goes
away and you and you believe the hype
yeah then then I I promise it will end
for you and you won't have to worry
about it you won't have to worry about
anything it'll just end fear is good
fear is good and you have the Panic if
you have the panic and you have the
constant of like you're like dude I'm
you know I'm it and it can't be manifest
manufactured it's got to be real but
that fear is good but you got to go do
the you got to go take the chances with
that fear you can't just stay protected
in like a scenario like there's a point
like it I mean look unless you want to
if you go do 10 Zanies uh all right so
what do you want to do 15 Zanies like
it's like right right like if you want
to then go do Mark's gonna move to Xanax
yeah it's but you know it's like there's
a point you go all right when you need
to go to a rhyming you need to go do two
rhyming you need to go do it otherwise
it's like what you know what are we
doing like it's right right you know
you're well you were the blueprint for a
lot of us because you know you you're a
dude that was you know ahead of us and
and we kind of watched your trajectory
and we're like well this is what you do
you know so we like we look to you we
all I mean because y'all both were guys
that did spots and worked and wanted to
work and you know and there's uh not a
lot of comics that uh want to work I
mean Comics that would you know I always
looked at as like guys that are like
well I take Mondays off right like I
remember that and I just was like I mean
just quit and it's one day but you're
like in my head you're just kind of like
we'll just quit then especially in the
early days especially in the early days
being like I don't go out on this day
you're like what are you talking about
you got to go out every night you gotta
you don't get to have that you you don't
get a you don't get to take Mondays off
maybe Mondays take off from Comedy takes
Mondays off for you but you don't get to
tell this you don't get to tell comedy
what it's not really on YouTube it feels
like it's not on your terms especially
at the beginning or the dudes with the
sense of entitlement like I remember
we'd hand out flyers and there'd be guys
who would be like why don't hand out
flyers I'm like well enjoy not going on
stage yeah yeah because you're not
[__] funny yeah like yeah yeah yeah
yeah we all hated it it was like you
just like that's what I have to do I
don't know what to tell you yeah like
it's like I don't trust me but you have
humility I mean we're talking about like
you know the fear and I think those
dudes are kind of like it'll work out
like they maybe they didn't have that
fear you watch them dude it's like how
how crazy is it to in your career when
you see because you see people jump
quick and then if you you stay on like a
steadier rise it's like you see them go
and then you see then you slowly get to
that level that they're at and you're
like is because people can make a jump
and then they just assume the next jump
will come yes and so then they well one
of the jumps is not going to come like
you're either people are going to see
through it or they're gonna you know
they don't build an audience right when
you build an audience you walk around
with an audience doesn't they're talking
about the Gaffigan thing you you when he
walks around with an audience uh Brad
Paisley country singer said the ones
like African can go sell out a 2000 seat
theater anywhere he wants to any night
of the week for the rest of his life
that's a lot that's a lot to be able to
go yeah and so to be able to go do that
to have that backstop to be like he's
not ever going to be a club comic again
right but he does clubs
yes Gaffigan will still pop into clubs
and he works on his [__] I'm a Gotham
last week yeah I mean he and he's a dude
that works I mean he's uh you get a
binder of new [__] and it was all
hilarious he's a dude also when I see
working out it almost always seems
finished which blows me I know it's
weird like that's not the way I work out
yeah I work out I'm kind of like
anything yeah there's a lot of that it's
a lot of is that something you know
that's how I built and I watch Gaffigan
I'm like that was 18 minutes without a
[__] hiccup I know it's new I'm like
I just did a Michael Richards set up up
there that was my new truck but let's
think about humility is let me say this
fun fact Marcus Aurelius the biggest
most famous you just go from Michael
Richards to Marcus Aurelius
this guy's got rain but he was the
biggest guy most powerful guy in the
world at whatever year that was and he
hired a guy to walk around with him and
tell him that he wasn't that great and
he said that's what kept Him focused
because it's obviously easy in Rome or
wherever the [__] he was to be just like
oh I'm the king I'm the [__] I beat
every Army I'm the man but he had a guy
going you're just a man you're just a
man you look just like veteran yeah yeah
but like guys who come on the street
like kiss his feet go Marcus Aurelius
saved my family I love you whatever he'd
be like oh thank you and then the other
guy would go hey you're no better than
him and he said that like kept him going
then he died of stomach the uh I bet
there had to be moments he goes I pay
you
like there has to be you know when he
goes you're just a man you go but
understand
I'm doing so good yeah I hired you I
hired you just to tell me I'm not good
all right right when you do show how big
a venue do you do in Tennessee when
you're in Nashville well this year we're
doing Bridgestone
so how many seasons April 15th uh don't
have Rory open you'll do them yeah where
do uh uh we're gonna try to try to sell
it out and it's I mean it's already at
like close to 13 000 tickets so oh my
God
we're trying to make it be uh hopefully
be completely sold out because I'm gonna
do it in the round let's probably do it
it's a big night I think this will send
it over yeah
so it's yeah that will be that'll be the
biggest show and there are already is
the biggest show we're like we have some
Arenas this year that are that are you
doing Arenas in cities and I'm like
that's a that's a hard City to sell out
and you're selling out uh well you got
to see some of them they sell some of
them they don't I mean like all that
stuff is you know some of like I was in
Jonesboro Arkansas like there was an
arena there because it's just not really
anything there to do but then they just
size it down I mean but we ended up
selling like I mean he still was like I
forget 1800 tickets or something but
you're in you know you gotta you gotta
look at that stuff sometimes because
it's hard not to you see people and
they're selling out everywhere or you
feel like they're selling out everywhere
and you can really get down to be like
God am I going backwards like this this
leg that we're doing this year we had
some Arenas set up in some places that
we moved on back to theaters before they
got announced and uh you know and I and
I got when I got told this it was like
kind of I mean I really it like hurt
like because it was like golly am I
going like is it not am I going
backwards yeah but then I have to remind
yourself like all right well I'm trying
to go to places that people are not
going and that are like you know that
not every comic game of America that's
what I'm trying to be okay right and so
you have to then you do there's going to
be moments of I can do Bridgestone and I
can walk out and it's going to be this
crazy show of my life to like I'm gonna
go somewhere else and it's going to feel
like you know you're like I don't know
if everybody here even knows who I am
right yeah and so but that's beautiful
and it keeps you humble I mean yeah I
mean that's a beautiful thing it's all
it's all humbling yeah so we're thinking
about the three of you if you take a
snapshot of you from like 2015 and it's
like just you know almost 10 years later
whatever the hell it is it's like you're
only doing theaters you're doing
theaters on a tour bus you're opening
you're I mean you're doing Bridgestone
people still and I just found no I
didn't mean to open it yeah
look at that oh that's wild I was given
the same speech
well you look great yeah yeah you look
great better it was a mess back then wow
I mean what year is that
yeah
2013. Molly yeah
10 years ago yeah 26th Street wow 10
years ago just take a minute and soak it
in it's incredible life is good I'm
grateful for everything yeah yeah boy
we all stink
Nate do you have any any pet peeves
anything that's bothering you just basic
life
uh something you can't stand it really
grinds your gears yeah trying to think
I think do you have one or yeah I have
one on my way over here the woman uh
the woman who's oblivious to by the way
we're in Times Square you got to keep
your head in a swivel yeah the woman
who's oblivious just blocking she's
trying to get on a bus she's having like
a small talk with the woman who's
letting people on the bus and she goes
and then I tell my friend I'm like shut
the [__] up move you know it's like may
as well just be a cone yeah exactly
exactly I'm with you on that I hate that
we've covered that before the guy who
sits in the Turn Style the guy who
stands and checks his phone to the top
of the subway stairs I think we covered
it maybe with someone recently the guy
who's ordering the sandwich yeah you
know what sandwich he wants yes at the
front you wait online the whole time it
happened to me in Nashville at uh Hattie
B's I wanted the real experience so I
wait online for an hour
and it's like six women all paying
separately all have no idea what the
[__] they're gonna hit they serve two
things here yes put it together yeah I
know they want substance
if I'm just kidding I always try to make
this to joke but I don't know if I ever
could uh but it's like the uh the eye
when someone says it doesn't hurt to ask
nah
because it does hurt someone right right
can I borrow 20 bucks doesn't hurt to
ask well that guy's out 20 bucks that
guy's out 20 bucks or he has to say no
which is not something people enjoy like
you don't enjoy being saying no to
something good point so you're making
someone
it's like you can go ask a million
dollars yeah you say no because then
when you get told no you don't go like
laugh at all you know there's a moment
of like you know you got the money you
know yeah right you don't want to ask
you that next time you should be like ah
[__] yeah
that's a good one that's a good peeve
that is a pee for sure that's a great
one right that could be a bit but mine
is so mine is so vague but I hate Dilly
dallying you know when you go all right
let's leave and they go all right
let me just check my phone real quick
this is women you're just talking well
just like get up and go and go you know
you're standing there and you're like I
want to leave so let's leave but they
have to like Dilly Dilly say bye to 18
people check their phone check their
[__] shoes tie this tie that like
just oh let's take Julie McColl on the
road oh is he a Dilly Dahlia oh here I
enjoy I mean he's the best but he's I've
seen uh you know those little uh cologne
bottles that you get that are glass yeah
that you can get like in a package that
they mail to you I've seen two of them
broke in my life and we're both by
Julian and we're both on my bus back to
back days I don't know I don't know how
to tour bus well I don't know who has
the little ones he brings the little
ones and he dropped them both in the
same spot on the bus separate days so
the bus just smelled like that
we find Julian's stuff on the bus like
everybody this week in Graham found a
watch a necklace uh he'll find his check
uh like it's all just kind of like he's
cool it's what you sign up for with
Julian all right well he's a funny guy
he yeah it's a it's a fun but I know
what you mean
I'll pay before yeah I'm done eating
let's just get out yeah when it's time
to go it's time to go I agree yeah no I
hate I hate that that's the whole reason
yeah I think you want to be a headliner
right just so whatever weird thing you
have
you're like I'm gonna make everybody
have to do my weird thing you know what
I guess you know what I did this week
no one on the on my bus really plays
basketball but I was like I'm buying you
all basketball sneakers today so you'll
feel guilty if you don't play with me oh
that's a headline and they and they I
bought them all Yana sneakers and we all
played every day damn yeah you play
outside or you play no we did outside
the first day in New Orleans but then we
did Rec Center holy [__] these kids in
Dallas could hoop man really you're
playing like 23 year olds after the
First full court game I was on my back
like ah and they were just laughing
these kids but I [__] I got back in
there but I was like I thought I broke
my back first yeah it was a cramp yeah
yeah but uh they came to the show too oh
really these young kids yeah that's my
problem I'm giving out tickets on the
road like crazy I have one good bagel
I'm like bring your whole family
I'll meet him yeah
just like you're killing me here this is
28 cops I remember opening years ago for
Jeff Ross and David tell at the Borgata
and Jeff Ross's green room it's like 40
people in The Green Room they're like we
met him at uh White House Subs you know
then I'm in David tells green room it's
just him alone with a cigarette yeah he
just looks up he's like hey that's great
it's hard not to turn Vibes yeah I can't
help it yeah yeah one good cup of coffee
I'm like yeah like what are you doing
come on bud yeah that's how you got that
10th show exactly exactly
you got to do 10 of just who you meet
yeah where do you work the bagel shop
you saw me earlier right right so uh
speaking of David tell he's the king of
humility he might have too much talk
about self-awareness where you're like I
suck I gotta write more he's that guy on
steroids yes he is he he's got too much
I mean he's he's the best he's the one
that's the most fun like I was yeah they
always say like when people uh
if I had to pay to go see someone it'd
be him same and it's like it's there's
no one more fun always funny always new
[__] and uh just always thinks he bombs
he'll murder and he's like slamming the
mic stand down like you guys don't get
me or whatever and it's all murdering
yeah he's the king yeah that's he was I
mean yeah coming up watching him
was uh I mean that was the that's the
stuff that makes I think you know that
sets a tone for kind of New York Comics
because you really gotta fit in a group
you were not a group or like a lot like
it was either like it was like the David
tale like you know which is like Burr
it's like all that like the New York
guys yeah I mean I guess I don't know
what the other group would be yeah well
you had your like Mark Baron Michael
yeah but Marin is watching him
I worked with him and uh I actually I
learned I mean I I learned a lot from
Aaron Marin is was what I wanted to be
when I would see Marin is I would like
try to marry and such him yeah on stage
true that it's uh I remember like being
like how do I get to be where it's just
that's who he is like if you see him
afterwards and see him on stage it's
essentially that exact same person yeah
you definitely have that and so to be
able to uh
try to you know because you're like I
mean the closer you can get
to your real life the more uh I think
the more material you you're open to oh
yeah oh yeah because you're just being
you so it's you know the more you can
just do this the more you'll be able to
talk about the more you know it's it
it's more conversational it's more
whatever it is right hold on
all right but let me just say this
I had nothing after that but uh sorry
that was a squeaker we had a we had
Jewish deli before this sorry about that
oh no you're good okay he farted it was
a whole thing he did it yeah yeah Nate
did I know supposed to be clean yeah I
want Market of a sitcom just so actors
have to walk in and he farts and they
have to pretend they like it yeah shoot
him a Gavin's like that's very funny
yeah he'll be he'll be kicked off like
Patrice on the office
it's so funny to see reruns you're like
that's Patrice O'Neal and he wasn't
happy to be there you could tell he's
like ah this is a shitty game you could
tell that one episode where he goes
something about like like you uh what's
her face cause her calls him a monster
or something like that and he's like
I'll show you my he says something kind
of aggressive
and it was uh
and you're like oh you're almost like
that's maybe the episode he got yeah
like it was like you know it's like the
show's very fun and stuff and then it's
a guy that you're like yeah he it's the
tone is very different not the right not
the right not the right tone yeah but
great show great yeah and great comedian
just not the right fit yeah yeah no he's
a guy you know they said he went to he
would bomb so much and he got banned
from so many clubs in America they had
to go to London he went for three years
Patrice yeah that's what will so Vince
told me he said in London he was a comic
in America he was a fat n-word that was
his line and uh that's his line so I was
like
so he wanted to just be treated like a
comic I want to work this I'm going to
text Will he's like yeah I never said
that he said it to will but he said the
word he lived in London yeah three years
because he felt like he they weren't no
one was getting him here they were kind
of just judging him like who's this big
guy
when you have an abrasiveness about you
in America sometimes it's a little bit
like this and then you go to London
you're like yeah that's how we talk if
he told me he never went to London I
would believe that Patrice I don't know
when he would have went to I've never
heard of this three years call Will
get him on the horn yeah he told me but
you know what his will do yeah yeah I
never uh
see I I remember when he got kicked out
of the comic strip there you go what do
you do with the comic strip he would he
would go up you know and like it was
they would drop checks and he'd go up
kind of the check spot and all this kind
of stuff and then he'd just be like the
waitress would be loud it's like that
it's kind of that balance where it's
they you know the waitresses are just
waiting tables they want to be done and
then he's on stage and it's like you
know you understand the frustration that
he's in and the fact that like they're
not you know but I mean he would just be
like they're not here to see you and all
this stuff and you come in just getting
arguments with them oh we're the only
entertainers that have to deal with that
[__] though that's true I mean and guess
what if a musician has to deal with a
check drop it doesn't [__] up their song
The Way It [__] up what we're doing oh
yeah oh yeah I mean that's why doing the
check drop is kind of how you get good
especially with an energy like like
yours you know like I mean I remember
doing check drops and I'm a low energy
guy too so I think people you have to
really have a good few jokes to get to
grab oh yeah yeah but I get a guy at
patrice's level was kind of not having
it makes sense too yeah well they they
yeah they would they would do it back
then and then he would just yeah he
would I mean I mean really be brutal
with the servers and you know and then
it's like that hey well they're just
being Services all this but you're like
yeah but there there has to someone
needs to step in and go but you have a
show yeah you're having a there's a
balance there's a there's a balance of
like a guy is on stage right and you're
just you can't just and be like a late
show or something and you're like I I
people don't know like what it's you
know when you're on there and you're
like you you think this is not fun yeah
like it's like it's in it's an almost
embarrassing they're drunk they're doing
math it's brutal yeah it's really like
it's not you know they'd be like doing I
remember uh doing a New Year's Eve once
today a State of New York yeah I
remember
yeah that's a tough gig and I was on
stage and I like staying in the
microphone I was like I don't know if
anybody knows that I'm talking no and
it's it's insane
you just say that to yourself and it's
crazy to be like in a situation in your
life the funnier thing to say into a
microphone yeah yeah no one's away well
no one is no one's even kind of aware
that you're doing that you're on stage I
mean I've been on shows where you're at
20 minutes in it's going so badly you're
like should we just like let's all you
guys hate me I hate you let's wrap it up
and you want them you want them to know
you're like I know this isn't going well
like I have a higher bar than this right
I just want you know I'm not bad and
lacking in self-awareness yeah you know
yeah yeah and the [__] usually works so
maybe it's a little bit on you guys I
don't know what I did in the beginning
to piss you off yeah when people say
there's nothing some comedians hate
there's no bad crowds I'm like that's
insane that's insane that's a person who
doesn't do bad shows yeah it never did
man ice and Fries thrown at me that's a
bad crowd yeah yeah yeah yeah you ate a
few of the things yeah where
Syracuse Funny Bone oh wow yeah so they
weren't even good fries no I ate them
but they were not good but you know
that's a [__] [__] that room
crunch it at me and I'm like Jesus
Christ what are we doing here you go to
that room and you're like there's a
reason this is the suicide capital yeah
like this is a dark this is a mall it's
eight degrees that's a long walk too oh
yeah and long walk to the stage right uh
that Pittsburgh improv used to I think
it's changed now Pittsburgh pretty good
yeah Pittsburgh is great yeah the old
and the the old one I remember uh and I
did there one weekend and uh this guy
was hosting and uh might have passed
away I felt like I heard that after but
he was hosted as kind of a big guy and
so that walk if you don't like real like
or or if you don't know but if you ever
go to Comic couple if you look at the
where the comic has to walk from to this
stage that one you had to walk down the
middle and it was a very long walk and
so so you would have to kind of be if
you're going to introduce you need to be
halfway and then once they start start
walking right
so I like we need and it's that thing
when they bring you up and you're
already kind of halfway down the crowd's
looking at you already I mean it's not
like I was really I was just headlining
but no one no one's really there for me
at that time and so then I get done and
so when I'm saying good night I look and
the guy hosting this kind of big dude no
it's gonna take him a while he's not
walking down and I'm like oh man you
know you're not supposed to leave a
stage empty or whatever like yeah and so
I'm like all right good night everybody
and then I look he starts walking and
you're like I mean this might be 45
there's no hustle there's no and you're
like and I'm like all right we had so
much fun keep it going for you they
forget their name you're like the host
is coming back up here
yeah
and he yeah he and he stops for a second
because he thinks are you gonna keep
going you're like no please come yes yes
please come there don't eat that there's
no music playing the awkwardness keep
doing this [__] yeah you like the queen
yeah thank you thank you everybody
you ever have someone have a heart
attack or a stroke during the show
that's a [__]
no yeah but uh no I never had that I had
a stroke and this is I was in uh stand
up Scottsdale and in Scottsdale I'm not
bragging yeah it's when they moved it to
a Mexican Phoenix
he puts me it was a nice club the first
time I was there and then the second
time I'm there he just rolls me up to
this place I'm like what's this he goes
this is the new venue it's the back of a
Mexican restaurant somebody like this is
gonna be a bad weekend you know and uh
I'm on stage and this guy this old guy
just goes uh he just knocks over a drink
and I'm like oh you know I do I think I
guess I'm doing pretty well you know and
then she goes he's having a stroke and
I'm like oh [__] yeah in the future
so I'm like you know like Jesus Christ
call an ambulance I stopped the show
obviously Howard Hughes the guy who runs
the show I don't know if you remember
yeah yeah I do remember he's got a great
heart yeah he makes some questionable
choices sure yeah so so uh he calls an
ambulance then he goes on I stopped the
show obviously I said let's see what
happens he goes on stage and starts
doing [__] with the guy who had the
stroke so he's like how you doing I'm
like dude he's having this you know how
he's doing yeah you don't ask that and
and the guy's just like ah and then he
finally sorry and then Howard's like you
know I've had a stroke I'm like you had
a stroke because you had 12 red bulls
and a ton of coke this guy's like 70.
you know yeah it's a Different Stroke
yeah yeah so finally they bring him out
and then uh I just have to go back on
you know you give it like yeah but like
this is a [__] brutal I thought of
the strip ones too the comic stripper
guy collapsed really I think that's a
jarring thing oh yeah for a person's
life to you know of course my this guy
might be dead is that Broadway Danny
Rose yeah you got to be funny You Gotta
Be You Gotta Have a line but not too
mean but cut the tension yeah that's
tough yeah Timber
that good you saw it coming yeah
I think I did those uh it's funny with
uh the stand-up Scots like those kind of
shows like I remember where you you go
do it one year and you're like oh it's
pretty it was it wasn't bad he booked
you again then it's out here like the
venue's different you don't think to
look into that no right and you're like
so I think you have to yeah you don't
think you look at the offer it says the
club yeah right and you're like all
right so we're the same place because
not a different part of town you go what
yeah you guys walk into a crack house
he's like look it's we'll work it's one
they're uh I remember where I did I
don't know if it was in Scottsdale it
was It was kind of it's got there was
some other place where they made you if
you if you had cops get someone with you
you had to pay for their ticket to get
in what and I thought I heard a story
with Pete Davidson headline there when
he was like 16 or 17 and he had to pay
for his mom's ticket
oh really that's a good person to make
an enemy with really on his career yeah
yeah let me piss off it's gonna be one
of the biggest comedy Stars yeah yeah
yeah that's uh that was a tough room
they would charge you for that was the
room in Staten Island looney bin yeah
that one I remember I got a Diet Coke
and then they uh they they charged you I
had to pay two dollars and fifty cents
it's like come on man yeah it's out of a
soda gun that cost you three cents yeah
yeah I I've got the famous story did
funny farm in Youngstown Ohio no longer
around the guy goes you want any dinner
I go sure you know I'm staying in the
worst hotel I got eight people there I'm
bombing and he goes all right get the
swordfish it's the best thing give me
the swordfish Ohio famous for that
there's a wine that pairs well I go give
me the wine I don't even drink wine but
if it Pairs and I get the bills like 260
dollars I was like what the hell is this
he's like we got the swordfish
oh my God so I think I was making 500
for the weekend it happened to me in
Colorado Springs at a club called
loonies with two e's and I remember all
weekend the guy's like you can have a
beer like yeah probably not he's like
[__] I was like all right so I started
pounding beers into the week and they
hand me a bill I'm like what the [__] he
called me a [__] I love that it worked
on you it worked yeah they charged for
all of them oh my God what a scumbag it
was Looney yeah it was terrible terrible
damn these clubs they [__] us they
make it yeah but it's kind of funny
looking it's very funny I mean that's so
funny to have to pay for a swordfish
yeah and now you go to clubs that start
there like here's the menu book with all
the menus of every restaurant watch out
of Bridgestone I heard they charge for
Waters yeah so take it easy over there
well that's you start doing theaters you
start they charge for everything that's
just a microphone you know like a god
mic can be on a thing if you want a a
god mic in some places can be charged
where you know that's what they say
about Madison Square Garden is like you
do it to do it and then you don't do it
you don't make any money no no and then
you do but you do it to do it I mean
like Dana White said that but they give
Billy Joel a deal well he doesn't uh
yeah if you do that kind of maybe do
that kind of thing but he's got like a
thing in the rafters yeah the Knicks
they might not give him a deal like it's
just like he comes down and I mean you
know it's like you don't make any money
but it's like I want to say if like
someone can make a million dollars out
of it like you might take home two
hundred thousand like or something like
wow I could be making all this I don't
know that would be hilarious I think you
left with like three grand yeah she
played the garden it's back to yeah you
had normal
25.50 yeah 25 15 travel by out right God
he goes all the way back to like we
won't cover Hotel you're like wow
they're really the garden the garden's
weird you can stay across the street all
right there's like a hotel Pennsylvania
there you go we got your room there and
you're like I gotta walk over right you
know but I know it's late we gotta you
gotta do found today right I gotta do
Fallon yeah all right thanks for making
time for us man it's great to see you
yeah too great to see you guys uh right
around the corner yeah everybody Amazon
new Naper gazi special and you're on the
road plug some dates
Vegas is just the late show in Vegas
Super Bowl weekend and uh Wichita Falls
Shreveport uh uh Tupelo Tupelo come out
Baton Rouge they're going to London
first time to Europe so I'll be London
Dublin uh Oslo Brussels Amsterdam
then Melbourne Florida oh boy that's a
wake-up call yeah come right back to it
yeah get in the thick of it uh-huh then
PNC Arena so this is an arena that's PPG
Paints Arena
same thing I'm paying 200 Grand to do it
making no money
uh yeah it's opposite are you doing
Bridgestone you don't do April 15th I do
bust oh you do bust lies yeah I was on
the bus this weekend I'm actually
getting a new bus uh because you can if
you get a bus you can I custom this new
bus and uh you just sound like a
three-year lease if they if you're gonna
do like a three-year kind of thing where
it's like I look at it as like I'm I
mean I don't see myself stopping touring
so it's whether how much I tour I mean I
don't know but it's uh so I just made it
where I have like the back the back area
now I still have the bunks I like a lot
of people on the bus so it's like it's
nice sleep well in the bunks yeah the
bunks are the bunks are great any of you
uh the back is nice to have you get your
own bathroom and all that kind of stuff
but I like the bunks because I just kind
of like a bunch of us on the bus like it
makes it fun it was fun waking up Vader
sliding the sliding the curtain and
farting in this
earlier I did the bus with Bert Joey
Diaz shangelis and big J yeah and it was
like a sleep apnea convention
hell I couldn't get a wing yeah yeah
even over the bus story
yeah yeah all right thank you guys yeah
thank you I love you all appreciate it
if you see the special it's gonna be us
on Amazon it's gonna be a killer what's
it called again hell
hello hello world on Amazon gonna be big
oh wait let's get a picture oh yeah we
got a gay photo
open up
Mark pluck some dates bro oh hey
I'm back in the clubs to run this
special folks uh I'll be with bird at
the uh the arena though we're doing
we're going to the Super Bowl then we're
doing Spokane Comedy Club Skyline comedy
club and Appleton
uh comedy to Carlson at Rochester then
we're in Chicago for the big taping then
I've been laughing up in Poughkeepsie
take a little break for the weekend come
back home uh Miami this weekend uh all
kinds of fun dates and we're back in
theaters after that so uh
markdormancomedy.com
I don't know when this comes out but we
got uh man what was it what
all right so what do we have February
14th Salt Lake City Utah yeah during the
week yeah through 16th we added a few
there uh Huntington New York Atlantic
City uh Royal Oak Michigan added there
added Minneapolis Madison Milwaukee New
Haven Boston we keep adding so you
better buy the Boston Wilbur tickets and
then uh you know Miami Orlando Punta
Verde we're adding a show there we got
Atlanta Charleston Durham
Charlottesville tickets still available
Norfolk tickets still available add in
DC we got [__] uh Wilkes-Barre Warner
it's unreal and uh Port Chester I can't
wait so uh love you guys and uh Bodega
catwhiskey.com keep on drinking we got
it we got a good thing going here we
love you yeah get some glasses get a
shirt and uh yeah praise Allah thank you
[Music]
and I get down in the same way
dangerous
[Music]
out to lunch here in New Orleans this
woman doesn't look like I remember her
and I get down in the same way
[Music]
true